il a mené la victoire de jacques chirac
pour la présidentielle de 1995 et celle
de valérie pécresse pour les régionales
de 2015 on le surnomme du coup le
faiseur de roi
aujourd'hui patrick stefanini et
candidat au départemental dans les
yvelines
il est en binôme avec josette gens dans
le canton de bonnières-sur-seine 50 ans
typiquement rural avec beaucoup de
petites communes des communes qui ont
moins de 1000 habitants
nous sommes dans un canton où il faut
beaucoup travailler sur les questions de
mobilité gestion des collèges
problématique des transports questions
de sécurité en zone rurale différents
points du programme du candidat du
groupe ensemble pour les yvelines
diplômé de l'ena en 1979 patrick
stefanini a occupé plusieurs postes dans
la haute fonction publique
il a aussi été préfet dans plusieurs
départements aujourd'hui il mène sa
campagne notamment auprès des maires du
canton merci beaucoup monsieur le maire
enfin comme préfet j'ai servi notamment
à clermont ferrand dans le département
du puy-de-dôme
j'ai servi à bordeaux dans le
département de la gironde j'ai
l'habitude de la relation avec les
maires et moi je mettrai au service de
notre binôme et à partir de là au
service de l'ensemble des maires et donc
de tous les habitants du canton
je mettrai mon expérience de l'état et
mon expérience de la région puisque j'ai
dirigé pendant plus d'un an les services
de la région du côté de
bonnières-sur-seine la gauche avec
notamment le parti communiste français
aura un binôme avec héloïse venancio et
pierre krasucki ce dernier est le fils
d'henri krasucki secrétaire général de
la cgt de 1982 à 1992 il a aussi été
membre de la résistance pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale est envoyé en
camp de déportation dans le bus de
beethoven là que vous voyez là sur la
leon ou des disques c'est ce qu'il avait
dans sa salle à manger
il était fou amoureux il adorait
beethoven à noël en 43 et s'est mis à
siffler la septième symphonie de
beethoven qui leur faisait tenir parce
que psychologiquement fallait tenir
pierre krasucki conserve aujourd'hui
tous les rituels de l'engagement
politique de son père la volonté de
faire quelque chose pour défendre les
gens assad
justice comme elles se produisent à
travers les politiques mises en place
depuis maintenant pas des parades
pendant la décennie j'ai milité pendant
près de 40 ans dans mon entreprise et
j'ai assumé toutes les responsabilités
de secrétaire d'un syndicat en passant
par délégué syndical élu c'est l'élu
seuil haut représentant ses os est hs et
finit délégation du personnel
toujours militant de la cgt pour les
retraités reste engagé au parti
communiste français
c'est sous cette couleur qui le
souhaitent proposer une alternance
autour d'une union de la gauche aux
élections départementales avec plusieurs
propositions notamment autour de
l'environnement la santé la solidarité
envers les personnes âgées mais aussi la
jeunesse il ya actuellement une
plateforme des monopoles et si je peux
dire le système scolaire cc midi je
crois et c'est me dit bon bah et c'est
une gestion privée or nous priver on
n'en veut pas on veut une gestion
publique
si son engagement et plus syndical
pierre razoux qui a une expérience des
campagnes électorales
il a notamment été déjà candidat pour
une élection cantonale et suppléant lors
des élections législatives de 2012